au lieu de déguisement de musique
satirique des pneus incendiés et un
défilé d'haïtiens en colère c'est nous
le peuple on prend la rue nous voulons
vivre bien nous voulons bien fonctionné
difficile de dater le début des
difficultés sociales en haïti à partir
de 1825 cette moitié d'île du nord de la
caraïbe première république noire libre
du monde doit rembourser l'achat de son
indépendance
au total l'équivalent de plusieurs
milliards d'euros résultat haïti est
l'un des pays les plus pauvres du monde
ce qui est nouveau ces dernières
semaines les protestataires sont des
policiers
ce dimanche à port-au-prince ils ont
pris d'assaut le quartier général de
l'armée
la première chose que nous demandons à
jo venelles et de réintégrer les
policiers licencie arbitrairement
seconde demande une augmentation
salaires et de meilleures conditions de
travail
le président nous a montré qu'il est
complètement inconscient le très
contesté président juvénal moïse assure
qu'il compte remédier à ces violences je
pense pouvoir dire qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
inspecté les conditions de vie précaires
des policiers jovial moïse fait face à
la défiance des haïtiens depuis son
élection en 2017
quant à cette dernière vague de
contestations elles durent depuis 2018
quand le gouvernement a tenté
d'augmenter de prix de l'essence de 38%
[Musique]